it took them about a week
it took them longer actually than I
thought that it would
but but the New York Times has finally
managed to make the Balenciaga
child porn story and attack on
conservatives it's it's hard for them to
do that
obviously very hard but they're they're
Adept at it I mean think about
how quickly you had that Maniac
non-binary member of the LGBT community
shoot up a gay nightclub and that was
somehow conservative's fault you you had
all sorts of these stories that they
always managed to turn it on
conservatives this one they were having
trouble though because Balenciaga is
beloved by liberals the face of
Balenciaga is Kim Kardashian but so many
other left-wing celebrities as well
the the imagery was so overt it's
exactly the story of stuff conservatives
have been warning about for a long time
that the libs are peddling
uh pedophilia and Satanism and you just
saw it right there on display in the
Balenciaga photo shoot but but now that
the New York Times headline is not
Balenciaga pushes weird Kitty porn stuff
that the New York Times headline is when
high fashion and Q Anon collide
okay I'm gonna put a pause right there
I consider myself pretty with it you
know I'm pretty involved in conservative
politics I've gone down a lot of rabbit
Trails I have read a lot of content on
the far right on the far left I travel
around the country speaking to
conservatives everywhere
I still don't know what Q Anon is do you
do you know what Q Anon is I know it
it's something to do with
Elite pedos which is just true obviously
like there's an island you know that
they all went to the Jeffrey FC note but
so I know it's something to do with that
but I don't I don't know the only thing
that I've really ever heard about Q Anon
is from MSNBC and CNN and the New York
Times I am not convinced that anyone
actually believes what Q Anon is
I'm fairly convinced it's just a fake
thing that the New York Times made up to
make right Wingers sound crazy because
what as far as I can tell the right
Wingers
look around at Jeffrey Epstein's Island
and they look around at the uh bizarre
Balenciaga photo shoot and look around
and everything in the middle and they
look around at drag queen Story Hour and
they look around at trancing the kids
and they look around at the child drag
shows where the weird men are putting
dollars in the clothing of the the
little kids dancing around and we look
at that and we say hey you guys are
groomers you guys are sexualizing
children you guys have a bizarre sexual
interest in children and that's really
weird and you also have a lot of overt
satanic imagery there in the drag shows
and in the Balenciaga and all and hey
that's kind of weird and we should stop
that
and then the libs
they come around and they say huh you
probably you crazy you probably believe
in Q Anon you say well I don't know what
Q Anon is I definitely believe in all
that stuff I just said though because
I'm looking at it because I saw it
happen I'm looking at it right now in
the Balenciaga website I said oh you you
Looney Tunes too crazy conspiracy there
you're probably a q a I don't know what
Q Anon is I don't but I don't but I do
know that what I just said is true and
is happening they're like there are
court cases about it it is for sure
there's an island in the Caribbean you
CR it's just a way to it's just a way to
pain conservatives as lunatics
for observing what they were doing and
so what did the New York Times say it
says two new Balenciaga campaigns
ignited a firestorm that traveled from
the internet to Fox News fueled by
allegations
that the brand condoned child
exploitation those allegations you know
those crazy allegations after Balenciaga
portrayed little kids who looked sad and
in distress holding s m teddy bears and
then in another ad campaign included
references direct references to child
pornography you know it's just it's so
weird how it fueled all those crazy
rumors what crazy allegations that are
obvious and right before our very eyes
if you saw balenciaga's child porn
campaign if you if you have noticed drag
queen Story Hour if you noticed that
these weirdos are going in and having
little kids dress up in sexual costumes
and dance around at gay bars yeah you're
you're just an Internet troll
with crazy allegations according to the
New York Times then New York Times
writes
as online criticism of the campaign
spread the story was picked up across
right-wing media Outlets including the
New York Post in Prime Time Fox News
show Tucker Carlson tonight the show
helped to publicize and mainstream Q
Anon
whatever that is the the internet
conspiracy theory that a group of Satan
worshiping Elites who run a child sex
ring are trying to control our politics
and media oh that's what Q Anon is okay
well if that's what Q Anon is then it's
just obviously true okay because I
haven't seen the whole Jeffrey Epstein
client book because the US government's
covering it up and the US government is
not holding any of those pedophiles to
account and the U.S government gave a
sweetheart deal to Jeffrey Epstein
himself before he got Epstein they gave
him a really sweetheart deal and they
let him live in what was essentially a
condo in Palm Beach though they called
it a local jail
and when the U.S attorney Alex Acosta
asked about it he was told don't touch
Jeffrey Epstein he belongs to
intelligence and I know that he was
paddling around with the most elite
prominent wealthy people all over the
world and they were trafficking very
very young girls to have sex with I know
that I know that for sure so what's the
part that isn't real
because I'm just talking about that one
the one aspect of what you're telling me
q a you're that's you're telling me
that's what Q Anon is well if that's
what Q Anon is
I've I have seen that reported in the
New York Times okay because even the New
York Times eventually had to report on
the Jeffrey Epstein story I've seen I've
seen the evidence for that
and I'm still seeing the cover-up of
that
and I'm still seeing weird child sex
stuff all around the culture that you
guys are promoting that the New York
Times is promoting in schools
in these drag shows in libraries
and I'm still seeing a defense of the
completely indefensible Balenciaga
campaign what's so amazing is the libs
haven't gotten their messaging straight
on this because the New York Times
argument here's this Balenciaga thing is
a total non-traversing crazy conspiracy
theory being pushed by poker Carlson and
it's nothing and it's wild and
but what did Balenciaga say
Balenciaga said this is completely
unacceptable we're so sorry Balenciaga
wiped its Instagram account except for
the apology Balenciaga said that it is
pursuing legal action against the people
who put the photo shoot together
so which is it
no big deal nothing Burger nothing to
see here as is the New York Times this
is extremely serious we're gonna wipe
out all of our our branding away we're
going to get rid of this photo shoot and
we're going to sue people into Oblivion
for doing it which is it
obviously it's the latter the very fact
that the New York Times keeps covering
up for this
well it's not going to dispel any
conspiracy theories let's let's just put
it that way
[Music]
[Music]